-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope everybody
is doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden claimed
in a new interview
that the coronavirus pandemic
is over.
Well, easy for him to say --
he just had it.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, it's over when
you've got the antibodies.
"I'm off to Burning Man and then
London for the Queen's funeral.
No masks. No masks."
CBS is facing criticism over
its decision to end coverage
of Queen Elizabeth's funeral
yesterday
in order to air episodes of
"Let's Make a Deal,"
and "The Price is Right..."
Though, if you're a fan
of those two shows,
you've probably seen plenty
of funerals.
[ Laughter ]
That's right -- They cut away
from Queen Elizabeth's funeral
yesterday to air episodes of
"Let's Make a Deal"
and "The Price is Right,"
or as the British Empire
used to call those,
foreign policy.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump has
reportedly said
that Florida governor
Ron Desantis stole his idea
to send migrants
to different states.
Also, his idea of standing
like it's your first time.
[ Laughter ]
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
recently dropped
on the Bloomberg
Billionaire Index
to the third-richest person
in the world.
He lost his spot when he bought
a Tesla.
[ Laughter ]
Former Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo spoke this morning
at the New Hampshire Institute
of Politics speaker series,
titled, "Politics and Eggs,"
I assume as one of the eggs?
[ Laughter ]
I-I assume.
It wasn't a joke.
It was an assumption.
I don't...
Pompeo criticized
President Biden
for his recent speech
attacking the MAGA movement,
and said, quote, "Treating
your countryman like enemies
is a rejection of the principles
that make America great."
Oh, so maybe they were chanting
"Hug Mike Pence."
[ Laughter ]
Tampa Bay Buccaneers
Quarterback Tom Brady apologized
on Sunday after throwing
a tablet on the sidelines.
To be fair, new technology
can be hard for boomers
to figure out.
[ Laughter ]
A lawyer in Kentucky was
recently suspended
after he allegedly offered
to help a defendant
in exchange for nude photos.
It's the rare case of a lawyer
trying to get himself off.
[ Laughter ]
Scollins? Yeah, Scollins.
And finally, Christmas is now
less than 100 days away.
Or, if you ask Costco, six.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.